TURN ON THE MUCH WE'RE GOOD
WILL GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO
THE E. YEAR WEDNESDAY EDITION
OF THE SENATE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT ALL OF YOUR HERE
WE MAY HAVE ANOTHER HEARING
TOMORROW OF PER THE REQUEST OF
THE VICE CHAIR SO I THINK YOU
SO MUCH IT'S A VICE CHAIR. LAYS
IN GENERAL WE HAVE ONE BILL ON
THE DOCKET FOR TEH THAT'S AB
TWELVE NINETY MISTER GLORIA SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE HAD TO DO
WAS GOING ON. AT WORK IN TURN
OVER IS LANCASTER TO GET
CALDERON SO MUCH MORE. YOUR
WIFE PRESENT MORE. PRESIDENT
BELL. PRESENT HERTZBERG AUTO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WRESTLING
CHESTER AT MEMBERS WE HAVE
SEVERAL OTHER COMMITTEES THAT
ARE HAPPENING AT THE SAME TIME
WE ALSO NUMBERS ARE NEED TO BE
TAKING THOSE IN OTHER
COMMITTEES WE CAN ASK THE
SERGEANTS IF IT WOULD BE
ALRIGHT LET ENERGY NOW THAT WE
HAVE A FEW FOLKS IN GOVERNMENT
FI IN TO BE A WHOLE THE ROLE
OPEN THE WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO
MUCH IN TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
MISTER GLORIA WE'RE GRATEFUL TO
BE WORKING WITH THEM YET AGAIN
ON AB TWELVE NINETY FOR SURE
SIR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND SENATORS. I WANT PEACE AT
YOUR CONVENIENCE MEANING HERE
AB TWELVE NINETY AUTHORED BY
MYSELF AND SENATE PRESIDENT PRO
TEM ATKINS THIS BILL WOULD I'M
STARTING A PROJECT FOR SAN
DIEGO. SECURITY BACK HOME AS
PURE WATER. BOARD THE SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE REVOLVING
FUND. DESPITE THIS INVESTOR
WORK ON THIS PROJECT HAS
STALLED DUE TO LITIGATION
CLAIMING THE CITY VIOLATED. A
SET LOCAL CITIZEN'S INITIATIVE
KNOWN AS MEASURE HEY THE
PROHIBITS MANDATED PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENTS. AB TWELVE
NINETY WOULD REMEDY THIS
DISPUTE BY MANDATING A P. L. A.
AS A CONDITION OF RECEIVING THE
STATE FUNDS. I WOULD NOTE THAT
MEASURE A SPECIFICALLY
AUTHORIZES PLA'S IF REQUIRED BY
STATE OR FEDERAL LAW. REQUIRING
THE USE OF P. L. EIGHT ON THIS
pPROJECT WE CAN PROMOTE THE
EFFICIENT AND TIMELY COMPLETION
OF THIS NECESSARY PROJECT. AND
MOVE BEYOND THE LEGAL
UNCERTAINTY THAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS AND THE COST OVERRUNS
ASSOCIATED WITH IT. ABOUT
MYSELF AND SENATOR ATKINS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
WITH ME THIS MORNING TO TESTIFY
OR THIS AFTERNOON. I ES GLENN
FERAL ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
COUNTY WATER. ESSAYS IDEAS THE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MAHER APPRECIATE THAT
OTHER TO TURN IT OVER TO.
MISTER FERRELL. A TO BE SOFT TO
MINUTES OR THE RETURN OF THE
CITY. RIGHT. GOV NOON MISTER
CHAIR AND SANDERS GLEN FOR ALL
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY WATER
AUTHORITY. THOSE OF YOU OF
SPENT THAT. CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT
OF TIME IN SAN DIEGO KNOW THAT
IT'S A REALLY VERY PROUD REGION
IT'S AT. HOME TO A VERY
THRIVING MILITARY COMMUNITY A
VERY ATTRACTIVE TOURISM
INDUSTRY. DIVERSE INDUSTRIAL
ECONOMY FROM BREWING TO BY A
MEDICAL TO. HEALTH AND TO A
HIGH TECH. THE REGION'S HOME TO
ABOUT THREE POINT THREE MILLION
PEOPLE. AND A BUS TO TURN
THIRTY PLUS BILLION DOLLAR
REGIONAL ECONOMY. HOWEVER JOHN
THE FLIP SIDE SENATE REGION'S
ALSO IT'S THE- WILL END OF A
VERY LONG WATER PIPELINE IN THE
STATE BECAUSE OF A LACK OF
PLENTIFUL WATER SUPPLY OPTIONS
THERE THE REGION'S FREQUENTLY
SUBJECT TO A PROLONGED DROUGHT
AND DROUGHT IS THE ENEMY OF A
THRIVING ECONOMY AND HEALTHY
QUALITY OF LIFE. THE PAST
COUPLE OF DECADES THE REGION'S
COLLECTIVELY INVESTED MORE THAN
THREE AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS IN. A WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY AND INVESTMENTS
WATER STORAGE. THE SONG NATION
WATER CONSERVATION RECYCLING.
WE'RE NOT DONE YET OF THOSE
HELP TO IMPROVE AND PROVIDE
SOME RESILIENCE IN THE IN THE
REGION BUT OTHER STILL MORE
WORK TO DO. THE CENTERPIECE OF
THE NEXT YEAR FROM A WATER
SUPPLY AND SENDING REGION IS A
C. SENDING US YOUR WATER
PROGRAM. THAT THAT PROGRAM
REPRESENTS. A LOCALLY
CONTROLLED WATER SUPPLY OPTION
IT'S NOT SUBJECT TO RAPIDLY
CHANGING CLIMATOLOGY NOT
SUBJECT TO. CHANGING HYDROLOGY
IN THE STATE. SUCKED IN THE
STATE'S SNOW PACK AND
AVAILABILITY. SO WE FIND THAT
TO BE AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
INVESTMENT IN THE REGION. TO
PROTECT OUR ECONOMY TO REDUCE
RELIANCE ON THE DELTA TO
IMPROVE. REGIONAL SELF
SUFFICIENCY AND WE- GREATLY
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA'S LEADERSHIP ADVANCING
AB TWELVE NINETY WE'RE STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR.
IT IS GOOD IN ANY OF TWO
MINUTES SIR. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN PROCESS OR THE OTHER
BEHALF OF THE STATE BILL AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
PROUD SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION. THE CITY
CALIFORNIA HAS AN INHERENT SORT
OF. INTEREST IN MAKING SURE
THAT THE INVESTMENT THAT IT HAS
AN INFRASTRUCTURE GOES A LOT
FURTHER. THAN JUST PROVIDING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WAS
GOING TO GET BUILT. WITH
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS THE
STATE ALSO. GETS THE
APPRENTICESHIP. NUMBERS HIGHER
BUT ALSO HAS. THE INCENTIVE OF
USING LOCAL WORKERS IT WAS
SAID THAT THERE'S A BIG A
COMMUNITY OF VETERANS IN SAN
DIEGO WE KNOW THAT. OF WHAT
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENTS ALLOW
IS FOR THE USE OF THE HELL
MISTER HARD HATS PROGRAM WHERE
WE ACTUALLY TARGET INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE RETURNING FROM
OVERSEAS OR FROM MILITARY
SERVICE. AND WE PROMOTE THEM
THROUGH OUR PARTNERSHIP PROGRAM
AND THEN ACTUALLY HAVE THEM
THROUGH THE PUBLIC TO THE
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT WORK ON
SPECIFIC INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THEIR LOCAL AREA. THAT CANNOT
BE DONE UNLESS THERE'S A
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT BECAUSE
OF THE COMPETITIVE BIDDING
RULES AND SO IF A UNION HAS A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
AND THEY HAVE THEIR MEMBERS ARE
WORKING FROM THE HIRING HALLS.
THEY GET TO SELECT WHO IS UP IN
THOSE CALLS HOWEVER WHEN
THERE'S A P. LA THE P. LA
BECOMES A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT THAT SUPERSEDES OUT.
SO WITH THAT WE CAN HIRE
VETERANS WOMEN. THIS IS AN IS
COMMUNITIES ALL WITHIN THE
LOCAL AREA WITH THIS PARTICULAR
BILL DOES. A LOT OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT TO NOT NOT
ONLY BUILD IT AND IT DELAYED
BUT ALSO APPLY THE LAW THAT WAS
PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
ELEVEN AND TWELVE. TO MAKE THAT
THE CITY IS ABLE TO UTILIZE THE
STATE'S INVESTMENT. NOW WITH
THE STATE INVESTMENT. CAUGHT UP
WITH THE LA NEWS OF THE PROJECT
EVER AGREEMENT BECAUSE OF PROP
A THE INITIATIVE THAT BLOCKED
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT ON
THAT. EARLY AGAIN. CITIES
COUNTIES SHOW THAT TRICKS
UTILIZED BY. YOUR BEEN TIMES
THOUGH WHERE SOME OF THESE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
PROHIBITED THEIR OWN SET THEIR
OWN SELVES TO DO SO AND SO WHEN
I SEND THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO
PUT UP PROP A THEY LEFT THE
CABBIE OUT THAT WHEN THE STATE
INTERVENE AND PARTICIPATED WITH
THE FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE IF
THAT FINANCES ASSISTANCE CAME
WITH THE USE THE CONDITIONAL
USE OF APPEAL HEY THAT THAT
WOULD BE ALLOWED IN TERMS OF A
PROJECT LABOR. TO APPLY TO THAT
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT WHICH IS TO BE
SURE THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA ASK
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE HERE FOR
SUPPORTING TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD FIRST CLASS
ORGANIZATION. IS WHAT YOU. SEE
WHAT YOUR BEST A SISSY SELECT
WORKERS TO CALVARY STATE
PATRIOTS COUNCIL THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS. CAL FORTY COALITION
UTILITY EMPLOYEES IN THE
ELEVATORS CONSTRUCTORS UNION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN AS A POINT OF
PERSONAL PRIVILEGE CAN'T THERE
BE A LIMITATION A NUMBER OF
GROUPS THAT ONE PERSON
REPRESENT.THEIR AGO. HI DAN.
WE'RE GONNA SEE. ANYONE ELSE
WHO MAY BE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IF YOU COULD PLEASE
ADVANCE. LAST CALL FOR SUPPORT.
WE'RE NOT GONNA TURN OVER THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSED IF YOU COULD
PLEASE COME FOR THIS TIME OKAY
PROPOSITION. WE'RE GONNA MAKE
ROOM FOR WE HAVE TO INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE ONE PRIMARY ONE
SECONDARY. WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE
TO KEEP HIS OFFICE ARE OUT
PRIMARY. STATEMENT THIS
REMEMBER GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
OF LEAVE A POINT IS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED
GENERAL CONTRACTORS A
CALIFORNIA THE SAN DIEGO IN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AND I
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LATENESS OF
OUR OPPOSITION UP UNTIL
YESTERDAY WE HAD A LETTER OF
CONCERN AND THIS MORNING MY
CLIENTS INSTRUCTED ME THAT THEY
ARE OPPOSED TO THE LEGISLATION
IS DRAFTED IN SHORT ORDER I
HOPE TO GET TO YOU THE LEGAL
RATIONALE FOR WHAT IT IS THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT BUT IN
LARGE PART. ARE OPPOSITION REST
IN THE FACT THAT. THE STATUTORY.
MEASURES THAT WERE MENTIONED BY
MISTER DE IS HAVE YET TO BE
TESTED SB NINE TWO TWO AND- SB
EIGHT TO NINE LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD WAS PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE IN THE AGENCY
SAN DIEGO WILL CONTEND THAT
THIS BILL WOULD VIOLATE.
CHARTER CITIES AUTONOMY IN
LARGE PART. BUT NOT TO A SORT
OF THE LABOR THE POINT ABOUT
WHETHER WHO'S RIGHT OR WRONG
UNDOUBTEDLY THIS LEGISLATION
WILL DELAY THIS PROJECT AND
UNFORTUNATELY. I'M NOT SURE
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT FOLKS
WANT TO SEE. BUT AGAIN MY
APOLOGIES FOR NOT HAVING THE
LETTER IN ORDER THIS GOTTEN A
MAN CAME PRETTY QUICKLY AND OR
LEGAL RATIONALE IS. OUT IN
TRAILING BUT WE WILL GET IT TO
YOU IN SHORT ORDER. THANK YOU
SIR APPRECIATE. THAT YEAH
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RICHARD
MARX AND ON BEHALF THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION OF PLUMBING HEATING
COOLING. CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE INDEPENDENT
ROOFING CONTRACTORS OF
CALIFORNIA A TWO MR OF FUENTES
POINT. WE ALSO AGREE THAT THIS
IS ACTUALLY GOING TO DELAY. OF
THE PURE WATER PROJECT WHICH ON
ITS MERITS IS A VERY VALUABLE
ADJUNCT FOR THE REGION. THE
REASON IT WILL DELAY IT IS OF
THIS BECAUSE OF THE
INTRANSIGENCE QUITE FRANKLY OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO. THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO WAS INFORMED THAT
THEIR DISCRIMINATORY PROVISION.
THAT RESTRICTED THE USE OF OUR
THIS IS ON THIS PROJECT VOTE
THEY DID THEIR OWN THE CHARTER
THEY REFUSE TO RESOLVE THAT.
THIS LED TO LITIGATION AND
DELAY OF THE PROJECT. IF YOU
ASKED TWELVE NINETY IF THE CITY
CONTINUES TO ALL THE JACK. WE
WILL. REACH HI. BUT WHAT WE
WILL BE MEETING IN. FOR THIS.
HE WILL GO THE PROJECT. IT WILL
HAVE TO RESUBMIT THE BID
SPECIFICATIONS FOR REBUILDING
THERE ARE ELEVEN CONTRACTS THAT
ARE ALREADY PREPARED AND READY
TO GO. TO BE RELEASED TO THE
SUCCESSFUL. RIGHT TODAY IF THE
CITY WOULD SIMPLY REMOVE THE
DISCRIMINATORY PROVISION THAT
RESULTED IN THE LITIGATION
WHICH IS WHAT BROUGHT US HERE
TODAY WITH THIS GOTTEN AMEND
THIS IS A BAD PRECEDENT THIS
FURTHER EVISCERATES THESE OF
THE UNIQUE POSITION THE CHARTER
CITIES HAVE IN CALIFORNIA. BY
RESTRICTING THE ABILITY TO
RECEIVE STATE FUNDS UNTIL THEY
ADHERE TO A POLICY THAT IS
DISCRIMINATORY AND IS ENTIRELY
DESIGNED TO KEEP NON SIGNATORY
CONTRACTORS FROM BIDDING ON
PUBLIC WORKS IN CALIFORNIA THE
SIX HUNDRED APPRENTICES FOR
WEAKER WOULD APPRECIATE A NO
VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE
BEING HERE. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
OPPOSED. TO SHOW INDIVIDUALS
WITH SPEAK UNDER OPPOSITION
PLEASE COME FORWARD. THIS CAN
BE LAST CALL FOR OPPOSITION.
I'M GONNA BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE TODAY TO SEE IF WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE FLOOR.
AND WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE SOMEONE OVER TO BE ARE
YOU MAKE ANY COMMENTS QUICKLY
IN AN ONLINE TURN IT OVER. IF
ABSOLUTELY WERE IN TURN OVER TO
THE VICE CHAIR AND MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH REMEMBER ANY ITEMS
THAT YOU WANNA BE ABLE BEFORE
WE TURN OVER TO COMMITTEE ANY
ITEMS YOU LIKE IN OPPOSITION.
WE GO TO THE VICE CHAIR AND
WE'LL GO TO THE MAJORITY. SINCE
pJUST CRIED A LITTLE HISTORY SO
IT'S ALL JUST STATE I'VE READ
IN AND MAYBE WE COULD. DISCUSS
IT BUT- IT WAS A PROPOSITION.
TWENTY TWELVE TWELVE. THANK YOU
NOT TO USE PLA'S WHICH PASSED
58% 2402% WE WENT TO COURT YOUR
WATER WE HAD A COURT CASE JUST
LAST MONTH RESOLVED THAT. THE
PROPOSITION WAS FINE THAT.
THESE WEREN'T REQUIRED. WE HAVE
A FEDERAL COURTHOUSE THAT WAS
RECENTLY COMPLETED ON TIME WITH
NO QUALITY ISSUES. WE HAVE A
STATE COURTHOUSE IN SAN DIEGO.
WITH DE LA THAT WAS FOUR MONTHS
LATER. WE HAVE THREE SYSTEMS
THAT NEED TO BE REPAIRED
REPLACED. AND I'M LOOKING AT
THE DEMOGRAPHICS AND I'M SEEING
THAT UNION SHOPS AND SAN DIEGO
ARE LESS THAN 10% OF THE-
WORKFORCE I AM. TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WILL WHY WE'RE DOING
IN IN RUN. WHEN THE VOTERS HAVE
VOTED. AND EXPRESS THEIR
POSITION AND WE HAVE A JUDGE
THAT TO CONCURRED WITH THAT. I
SAW AYE AYE I THINK THIS IS AN
AND IMPROPER VENUE AND TOUCH
WITH. ROBBIE VOTING NO. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE VICE CHAIR.
WILL HAVE THE SAME NUMBER
ADDRESS THAT IN JUST A BIT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER AND. OKAY ALL RIGHT. DO
YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
FROM THE COMMITTEE THIS TIME.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION A MOTION BY
CENTER TADO IT TO DO PASSED THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS WERE
TURNED OVER TO THE SOME NUMBER
TO BE OF A CLOSING. IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADDRESS THE VICE
CHAIR ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT WE ARE HERE BECAUSE OF THE
OPPOSITION'S A LITIGATION OVER
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT AND YOU
HEARD THE COMMENT THAT THEIR
FEARS ABOUT THIS WOULD
LEGISLATION DELAYING THE
PROJECT. YOU DON'T GET TO HAVE
IT BOTH WAYS THEIR LITIGATION
HAS DELAYED THIS PROJECT WE'RE
PROJECTING ABOUT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS IN LOST TAXPAYER FUNDS
MONTHLY BECAUSE THIS ONGOING
LITIGATION I UNDERSTAND CITY
COUNCIL YESTERDAY IN SAN DIEGO
DECLINED TO SETTLE THE CASE AND
SO WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO
PERSIST IN THIS. UNLESS WE TAKE
ACTION MEASURE I AM I BELIEVE
I'M THE ONLY PERSON IN THIS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THAT CAMPAIGN
YOU MIGHT NOT BE PRIZED AYE
OPPOSED IT. I'M MUCH WAS MADE
BY THE PROPONENT. THAT THIS. SO
THIS IS MEASURE. EXEMPTED IT'S
STATE OR FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT
MANDATED PLA'S. THAT WAS WHAT
THE PROPONENTS OF THAT MEASURE
SOLD ON IN ORDER TO KEEP. THIS
IS THE CITY'S ACCESS TO STATE
AND FEDERAL RESOURCES. SO THIS
LEGISLATION. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE AND- FROM THE-
COMMENTS OF THE PROPONENTS OF
MEASURE A IN TWENTY TWELVE. IS
PERFECT ALIGNMENT. BASICALLY
THE IN THE DAY BUT I'M TRYING
TO DO IS IT WITH LAW CENTER
ATKINS TO SECURE THE WATER
FUTURE OF OUR- STATEMENTS. AND
ON A WATER WE CREATE LOCALLY IS
A GALLON WATER MIGHT TAKE. YOUR
CONSTITUENTS. I'M IN SO I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY. TO GET
THIS PROJECT OFF TO FIND. HIM
TALKING ABOUT IT FOR A-
DURATION. I'M NOT ONE TO JUST
KEEP TALKING. I WANT MY GOD
LET'S GET THINGS DONE. TO VOTE
TODAY WILL SECURE THE WATER
FUTURE FOR THE THREE MILLION.
PEOPLE IN OUR COUNTY I ASKED
WAS FULLY FOR YOUR EITHER. TOO
MUCH IT LAYS INJURED ON THE
MOTION ON THE FLOOR IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
ASSANGE'S ROLL CALL PLEASE. I'M
MORE LARA. NOBEL BELL I
HERTZBERG. GOD RICARDO HELLO I
NIELSEN YES I WIENER AYE WIENER
HIGH. THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT
BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSE THE
ROLE WE ARE NOW ADJOURNED WE'RE
GONNA MAKE ROOM FOR THE NEXT
COMMITTEE WE APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY COMING TOGETHER. THEY
SENATOR